we don't have many details about rajiv
badawi's release or the conditions of
his release but we do know this
merci merci
merci is badawi's wife and sav hadar who
reacted to the news friday afternoon she
says it's great news for everyone thank
you thank you she spoke at a vigil in
sherbrook where she lives with the
couple's three children badawi was
arrested and detained by saudi arabian
authorities in 2012 on charges of
insulting islam he is a blogger and
human rights activist who encouraged
debate on religious and political issues
in the country despite the restricted
civic space many organizations including
lawyers without borders and amnesty
international have been pushing for his
release this is the news they've been
working towards for nearly a decade
it was so amazing for me i felt so
submerged by my emotion i was even i
even cried i must admit when it happened
um because i mean i've worked so much
with this but i've worked with and staff
with the family he's still sentenced to
paying a a very harsh fine monetary fine
and is still the subject of a travel ban
a 10 years 10 year travel ban
that 10-year travel ban would prevent
badawi from traveling to canada and
finally reuniting with his family both
organizations say that people and the
canadian government need to keep
pressure on saudi arabian authorities
amnesty international has organized a
vigil on thursday in front of the
building that houses the organization to
demand badawi's full release
gloria enriquez global news montreal